[Music]  lawmakers are beefing up an information  sharing system between Schengen States  to support border control for example  new alert categories for migrant return  decisions and unknown wanted persons  will be added the European Parliament is  hosting a high-level conference on clean  energy financing several experts and  high-profile figures look into the best  way to finance the transition from  carbon to more sustainable energy  sources members of parliament and  Commission of France Timmerman's discuss  respect for rule of law in Poland the  Polish government recently implemented  constitutional reforms that critics say  restrict democracy despite US president  Trump's decision to a draw from the  Paris climate agreement California has  pledged to continue implementing it  lawmakers and California's Governor  Jerry Brown discussed how to move  forward with initiatives